well of course I mean oh and it's still
it's still based on the the same
principles of what I think comedy is
about you know I think there's a big
difference between comedy and and and
sense of humor and I think that a
comedians job isn't just to make people
laugh that's easy that could be a reflex
I mean you see some comedians that it's
the rhythm they can even throw in a
punchline they'd get a laugh and I think
it's about many people think about it
and why it's funny and and I think
comedy is about empathy I think you know
I can't laugh people I don't like I
think you should never be above the
audience and there's nothing remotely
funny about seeing unfeasibly handsome
brilliant people come out and tell you
why they're brilliant I want to see a
putz losing his way falling over and
getting back up and dusting himself off
and and you've always got to see that
that humanity that sort of struggle in
anything really as opposed to change my
personality no I don't but of course
everything you do is got got persona
chat shows I'm playing a sort of
character it's not completely me you
know I never let my guard down at an act
when I'm on Letterman or Jon Stewart I
don't act completely like I do with my
friends you know you still edit yourself
you still you still present stand up
again it's at this episode I play a
Brasher more arrogant more confident
version of myself and and then there's
another level on that that I usually
play the guy who says the wrong thing
you know the target of my my stand-up
scene like there's soft targets but of
course the target is the audience's own
prejudice and middle-class angst and me
I mean I'm always the butt of a joke I'm
ignorant I come down on the wrong side
Joe Collier Nelson Mandela what a great
guy often gets a round of applause I go
incarcerated for over 25 years released
in 1990 he's been out now for
nineteen years and he hasn't reoffended
I think he's going straight it shows you
prison does work so I always played
getting it wrong you know and then in
the characters I play you know from from
David Brent to Andy Millman dr. Pincus
in ghost town they're they're variations
of each other I always play that that
that putz that that wisecracker in the
face of adversity and I I don't
apologize for that I've never seen this
thing about an actor trying to show his
versatility due to a casting director I
cast myself to the audience I don't care
all my favorite people have done one
thing well forever
Woody Allen same character Bob Hope same
character Groucho Marx same character
different situations you know even great
actors they play they play versions of
themselves they play it with their voice
their Dustin Hoffman you know it's I've
never impressed people going all all
they wear 3 different wigs in that I'll
go who cares you know things like I know
sketches and those they don't resonate
they don't mean as much as a character
that that's got a full development and a
narrative and I've always my outlets
always been the other the other
characters that I create in the office
it excites me much more to be the
creator and the director of every other
character in the office than me putting
the wig on and and doing it you know
that that's a Pyrrhic victory for me
because it you can't suspend your
disbelief so that's important to me
realisms always been important to me